dude so let me tell you who came out to
one of the shows
triplets brah you know what I'm saying
dude sometimes the womb stutters a
little bit and it makes but babies you
know it makes them [ __ ] bad boys dude
in these guys it was like there was a
little Neapolitan sandwich man I did
these boys they were beautiful boys and
they all they would finish each other's
sentence one of them would start to
blink a little then one of them would
blink a little more than one of them
would fully blink and I was like what in
the [ __ ] is going on and these boys were
just a living batch of dark art if you
see if you see these fellas they're over
there near I Atlantic City I think they
came out in and they there was triplets
and they said dude were triplets and I
was like [ __ ] what dude the singers
and they're like what and they said no
we were all born at the same time I said
damn y'all that [ __ ] batch y'all that
batch and they would do it was crazy man
they would you know you tell one of them
a joke and the other one would [ __ ]
laugh man even listening to him it was
like playing you know conversating with
him it was like just just dialogue
dialogue you know just like dialogical
whack Amole you know you'd be over here
with an answer and then BAM the question
no and then you know it was unique it
was like playing the shell game you know
you ever come out of a supermarket and
they got that brother out there with the
cardboard and he got the little nutmegs
right there and one of them's got a
little wall you know little nugget of
coke or something under or a little
pecan and he's flipping those things
around and bouncing them with the carts
and next thing you know we think you
over here talking about shellfish and
then BAM [ __ ] contestant number three
hits you with a [ __ ] conversation
about zoning in his area you're like
what the [ __ ]
and that you would triplet you got to
stay alert with triplet you really got
it's almost like you got to do one at a
time you know you got to do like this
what's up duh what's up dude you know
hey buddy how are you and you so you got
a section them off by their dead look
they were beautiful boys they all looked
pretty healthy and um and I told them
straight up I said hey look if you guys
are like the Transformers or whatever
like because I'm thinking these dudes
are gonna do to do autobot [ __ ] one of
them gets into a little set you know a
set of legs and then one of them torsos
up and the third one [ __ ] morphs into
a head and then they wander off just one
guy working over there but a [ __ ] you
know about a Jersey Mike sort of fedex
kinko's but it's why when you meet him
if you see if you see triplets man you
just let them know you support them do
your best that's all we can do good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one